ahora que tienes una idea de cómo
funciona te estamos listos para calcular
nuestro punto de intersección y entre
nuestros rayos cp y nuestro segmento
lineal ave recuerda del vídeo anterior
que la forma pendiendo intersección de
la línea ave es que equivale a menos 13
x + 11 y la representación paramétrica
del rayo cp es la función r dt es igual
a 1 - t por c
master por p
los diferentes valores del parámetro te
ubican diferentes puntos en el rayo
el punto de intersección que buscamos es
uno de estos puntos en el rayo así que
debe haber algún valor de t llamémoslo t
asterisco tal que y sea igual a rd t
asterisco
estas son realmente dos ecuaciones una
para la coordenada x de iu y otra para
la coordenada y estas dos ecuaciones son
y su x es igual a 3 v x dt asterisco lo
que equivale a 1 - de asterisco x se
sube x + t asterisco por p sube x
de la misma forma y sub es igual a rsvp
asterisco lo que equivale a 1 - t
asterisco porsche sub master asterisco
por p sub
en este caso particular de nuestra
posición de cámara tiene las coordenadas
0 0 y p tiene las coordenadas 2 un medio
por lo tanto tenemos y sube x es igual a
t asterisco por 2
y su bien es igual a te asterisco por un
medio
y también está en el segmento lineal ave
de manera que satisface la forma
pendiente intersección para ave es decir
y sub es igual a menos 3 por iu sube x +
entonces tenemos tres ecuaciones y tres
incógnitas y sube x y sube y te
asterisco
podemos solucionar el sistema de
ecuaciones sustituyendo las dos primeras
ecuaciones en la tercera para obtener
una ecuación solo ente asterisco
un medio de té asterisco es igual a
menos 3 por 2 porte asterisco más 11
resuelve esto párate asterisco y luego
introducir ese valor de asterisco en las
primeras dos ecuaciones para obtener y
sube x e y sube y así es como se hace
antes de continuar práctica este tipo de
función paramétrica en el siguiente
ejercicio